this week we've got bathroom burglar
black hole and parking solution can I
guess they stole toilet paper I did that
when I was broke damn you too my first
apartment I used to go to the communal
bathroom and take toilet paper that's
stealing
I took it in college there was a
communal bathroom in our party well like
the know like the leasing office like
hey you use the bathroom I would go in
there and take some I appreciate y'all
man they got smarter though cuz they
lock that [ __ ] no really yeah you can't
get off the roll they locked the toilet
tissue so I always write in that one
place underground with my buddy Michael
and he has this bathroom there and I
used to be able to grab the toilet paper
from there but now he gets all locked
dude so now you just gotta roll it on
your hand and pick out why that's
exactly this one you bring your own
empty need to roll it back at home what
the [ __ ] going on with your toilet
paper and you're like hey it was free or
you say [ __ ] like I made it
one-one thing that I still do is collect
napkins oh yeah we have the condiments
right there we also don't you know
you're not prepared for the future
yeah I have so many napkins all over my
car me too yeah man I can know where the
napkins are in our house because I but I
boycotted them I was like paper towels
are bust I like it I have paper towels
too but you know what I'm saying well
that breaks a bank with paper towels you
can I use it like crazy the perforated
half sheet quicker picker-upper
no but that's way too expensive good the
[ __ ] Kroger is one dollar you got it
but you can't go cheap paper towel thing
you got to pay for the Kroger wanteds
goodie is it hard though I think you
have your watch how absorbent is it I
don't know
at kirtland's good the definition one
where you're pulling it and that gets
like tearing off every I disagree with a
[ __ ] Kroger one is strong bro I need
it and you know it's strong I want to
eat sandwiches off of it like no dishes
no dude you gotta be strong enough to
this will and cuts limes and lemons on
the paper towel on the granite counter
yes what Nicki literally the cutting
board [ __ ] is the counter because it's
a granite countertop oh my god so that's
the whole cell we see what do what do
you that's why people buy grant accounts
I've seen account do you can come no
longer in it know you supposed to
protect it you're stupid you're so
stupid I roll on it cuts in the
non-stick frying pan he cuts directly
either [ __ ] 10% Byron first of all
Byron I'm calling you a [ __ ] bread
from the toaster with the metal
important no I use my hands I use my
hands like a non-person this [ __ ]
savage I wouldn't because that's very
dangerous but I will say this I use a
butter knife on the counter
not a [ __ ] Sharpie that's not true
either his truth about the Sharpie boys
what dude you put the paper towel first
and then you get the line yes no and
then I go up sit down with a butter
knife in it yeah but it doesn't cut the
paper yes it it doesn't cut the baby yes
it does it does not cut the paper this
has been bothering her for a while so
little it's boy line no here's the thing
when it's when it's clean you're right
it's it's in the sink right but when
it's not there we also have these little
plastic [ __ ] how long do you look before
you give up and go for the paper time he
doesn't look he look he goes like this
can't find it pretty much you don't even
have to cut it this way too if you want
you could just hold it and go like that
dude you're a [ __ ] genius
that man is a [ __ ] G have the weapon
of your finger I hope you do I will
you'll see good I'll show you what I'll
do it no webbing looks like you gotta
hold my hand I got no weapon you know
you know I'll actually do did we have a
little bit of a grand backsplash I'll
put it up against that come at me bro no
if you even thought of that that's where
the [ __ ] cutting board is you stupid
over it really and lean up against the
[ __ ] back so you need to be in the
past
I see the residue of the book a cutting
board every market juice on the granite
countertop first story oh yeah we can
scramble here then they steal all member
this has nothing to do it's my River so
deputies surrounded a home in Oregon
because they were responding to a 911
call of a burglary in progress turned
out to be a Roomba stuck in a bathroom
wait what they heard something and there
was a room but about cops pull a gun on
the room but all my where I could see
literally came in with their guns drawn
do you think you're making the same
noise like dude this is the kind of [ __ ]
ours is crashing into things
this is the kind of [ __ ] that Calabasas
Police Department has to be [ __ ] a
doggo room bizarre out of control they
don't respond a direction I was like
something's going on in the backyard
what's going on and they're like man
that [ __ ] jacuzzis on she's like oh
Jesus we'll call me a pig when I'm I had
lint in the middle of the floor and now
it's gone yes the first stage of robots
taking over in Roombas not paying
attention disobeying orders you clean it
up they close the bathroom door like
this could be a whole documentary like
Beverly Hills raining like Reno PD
before Burrell that's yeah yeah I missed
that show man a bad show totally
underrated man so good honey man perfect
mr. Nash is so funny in there that
should be all worth they all work Thomas
Lennon yes Oh Jerry Terry so yeah
they're saying that this woman she
called my mum one because she heard
noise and her bathroom she got really
scared and she could see a shadow like
and she forgot the room but was on well
it was trashed and there's some house a
very thoroughly vacuumed job they're
outside with their guns like put your
weapon down kick the door in in a robust
just like yeah you'll never take me
alive or the room but never came out so
they're like we're gonna be the FBI dude
this guy's [ __ ] tough this guy is hard
he's still robbing us while we're a bit
out like we need a hostage negotiator
these guys not coming out city tax
dollars are paying for this I love it
man no they're taking our paychecks yes
because I got guys Roombas and so the
first ever photo of a supermassive black
hole has been oh yeah it looks like a
dragon's eye so I first saw this on
Twitter and some money photoshopped
hands to make it look like a butthole
it's literally all I can see now wait so
what are we looking at is that our
shadow of a black light so all the light
around it is like stars that are all I
can afford er to capture this photo it's
like you're standing and let's just just
suck it up Suns so you're standing in
New York trying to get a photo of or
trying to count the dimples of a golf
ball in California
like that's how far away I could make
that in Photoshop turning but it's so
cool so what's this the telescope this
is how far away this black hole is oh I
love this [ __ ] I'm glad it's far away
now get big the galaxies yeah man
they're saying I forgot how I feel so
tiny when people do aliens at times and
bigger than our Sun or it's like the
size of our entire solar system it have
you ever seen that one where it's like
that just sucks a lot oh [ __ ]
have you ever seen the meme of all the
different stars and how they stack up
compared to our stars and I could get
the Betelgeuse and you're like holy [ __ ]
we're so small it's like the end of men
in black yeah Jesus dude was how far
away this [ __ ] is you know woman a woman
was the lead on this missus why they you
believe she had a brain big enough to
think of that you want to lie to her
about where you were last night you want
to try to cut alive on a cutting board
or not a cutting board because I do
agree that a woman was doing that
because they have laser point for
because they will find yeah they will
find like things that I didn't even know
existed yeah it'll be like the holes in
your story they'll be like a little
you'll be like in the bathroom and they
can see the smudge on the kitchen
counter that you made how's that even
possible I have no idea we have eyes
everywhere all these hard drives of data
they used to have just like crazy yeah
they're saying that they had together
this was the equivalent of 5,000 years
of mp3 files like that's how much data
and holding it throw a tracker in there
now we could finally like figure out
what happens if that was right next to
us we would be like dude I'm so glad how
far away it isn't like that so sing what
if that is like the galaxies vacuum
cleaner that's the back galaxy the robot
it is it is just spitting it out or what
if we're in an artificial gallic like
artificial created universe and that's
just like a part of the programming yeah
like a reset button oh yeah I was
thinking like a Bitcoin like you know
like though computers think that they
had to do all this work to find this
Bitcoin but we just put it there great I
never understood how bitcoins were mined
well I'll just good job
so me later so I did a podcast about it
yeah they don't tell you pop good listen
did I have that okay I'll tell you but
yeah so they're saying that this black
hole is 6.5 billion times more massive
than our Sun they don't gotta brag about
it this is why they kind of dumb it down
for us though where they got to be like
hey it's like looking at Los Angeles
from New York and like you're looking
for a [ __ ] quails head or something
because otherwise people wouldn't care
and they'd be like this all this work
and no one cares it just sounds like so
much it's like when I hear Bill Gates is
a billionaire like man that's so much
money I can even think about that [ __ ]
well so finding this photo though it's
early creating this image it it's a
humongous deal because they're able to
like solidify the theory of relativity
Einstein's theory of general relativity
and it's just giving astrophysicists and
unprecedented close-up of an actual
black hole so then we get to learn more
that's a close-up that's so that's the
closest black hole we ever it's the
biggest one
that's the first one they first one they
took a photo and that's pretty good rest
for all that I know how they do that
they took five saddles like it oh man I
don't know wait no not five five
continents especially just like a blur
that looks like a blurry solar eclipse
yeah wait a [ __ ] all over the [ __ ]
achievement we're looking at a light
silhouette around a black hole that's
what you're looking at proof of
something that didn't exist like I knew
it existed nobody needed to prove that
type of Flat Earth people are probably
like this is planted of course it's a
composite image they're saying that it
took a group of eight radio telescopes
that are stationed on five continents
that all observe the same area of space
over the course of one week in April
2017 and so they were able to collect
all that data that's probably did it
take two years to process that image yet
they needed supercomputers to actually
process all the data to call this now
the first had to build the
supercomputers to the process that is
how a lot of this [ __ ] is that's why
we're never morning shits all over space
stuff and they're like well what does it
do for us I'm like dude all the [ __ ]
that they've had to do to get to those
places has been technology that's
enriched all of our lives in ways that
you don't even know but just to get us
to the moon they came up with where we
are exactly
so the moon landing but who wouldn't
have tang without that time could
possibly be like oh that's true but it
doesn't affect my life or my Starbucks
point so residual space exploration
helps us yeah [ __ ] yeah dang it velcros
good enough GPS we use it all the time
I'm like thanks for technology that's
why you have porn on your fingertips
exactly that's kind - I was reading
something that there might in the worst
cold on the moon as there is on like on
the earth or like a ratio like the same
race we did you just say there's just as
much gold on the moon there they were
thinking that there is and then they're
also doing research to see if there's
that much gold on Mars or if the like
mission to go there to find the gold
would take would cost more than that oh
my god like a new era of gold rush it
was so reason why that's what I'm saying
that's so sick so now we're like dude
doesn't send to go to the [ __ ] there
was oil on the moon we did invade it is
dead
or did and we would bomb the [ __ ] out of
the moon for some reason because that's
what we do nobody on their dues will
shiver cruise ship Libyans to the moon
so we could bomb them while we take the
oil because that's the tradition
ya know terrible terrible how do we get
back to politics that's reality bro it's
capitalism that's right
alright well moving on to our last story
there's this new app that aspires to be
the Airbnb of parking hmm we rent their
parking spaces out like in Hollywood or
New York or big cities like that that's
genius
well so this started at the San Jose
State University it's been active there
and this app is called
parks - this is what it looks like
people could rent out their driveways
for University students because they
take up so much time to actually look
for a parking space it's best genius
that is genius
you know students are paying a certain
amount of money for their parking pass
it's expensive I think there's like
15,000 students in the school there only
5,000 parking lots yeah it's pretty
stupid too because even if you pay for
parking for school you could never find
Park okay yeah that'll be over book it
yeah that shouldn't be fair that like
illegal that's like the airlines like
when you think about it changing the
name on a ticket you purchased having to
pay for that is ludicrous yeah now
they're charging a lot because they're
all like working together their lines
what a shocker that's what do you
remember do you remember having to pay
for checked laggin luggage you still
have to write told me back at me back in
the day you never had it too bad for you
it's a new thing you never had the
favorite [ __ ] meal it's because after
9/11 people were too scared to air
travel so a bunch of airlines went under
so the way that they could actually make
money so that they could continue to
have airplanes was they have a charge
people you know what I recently read to
that back in the day it would only take
I think five hours or something to get
from LA to New York but then now it's
like six hours plus and that's because
they add in
time because back then lights would
always be delayed because they they were
just not efficient enough to run their
the system so now instead of making
their system more efficient they've just
added more time to the traveler they
will say delayed so then that's why I
make an hour of time in we eat all costs
so that's how it works yeah that's like
you want to tax the company if we're
gonna get the kickback what you gonna do
like when you think about what your
flights cancelled or they bump you baby
like what you gonna do walk shut up
you'll deal fly what we tell you to fly
listen when you're in another country to
your den here the ultimately [ __ ] and
there's less competition to so you only
have Delta American Airlines and United
who are the main yep dude and those are
the worst ones by far but they can be
like Delta I'm and I'm in Medina what
the [ __ ] were you raised going on
Emerson Airlines it's better than Delta
sounds like a [ __ ] offbeat airline
American Airlines they shot United's
okay but they lost my luggage twice dude
United is the United is the insignia of
LCD TV a little bit there I think
they're a little bit cheaper sometimes
yes shitty not it was the first one to
have main cabin where you can't check
you you have to check your bag I mean
you can't even carry it on like the
cheapest seat available you cannot even
bring a carry-on you can only bring like
a backpack or purse on you have to
I don't like checking bags I don't like
traveling I should never check bags but
now when I go and I travel I'm always
have like merch and stuff so it's just
like necessity yeah but they lose your
bags man they've had so many times
they're like oh yeah your bag never made
the flight like what was he busy didn't
stop my chick-fil-a I know that's your
whole job they're like actually have you
smartass we found your bag of chips
right so do you think I've had a bad
completely loss like never returned
needs a bag full of merch a little
t-shirt you have to reimburse the club
yeah they reimburse you but it's like a
flat fee of like 150 bucks
what and it was like a thousand
emergency memories really yeah airlines
money that's priceless see that's why I
don't try I don't trust them I don't
trust I had a friend who worked that job
they can't paid minimum no benefits and
he says no joke people are opening
luggage and stealing things
my friend it happens they they open it
so you should for sure get a lot a good
tarp but there's a way to open it even
with the lock that's why I have the
shadiest looking luggage really oh yes
Marv my luggage looks like [ __ ] dude my
luggage looks like it got [ __ ] sent
to Uganda I like like on a bike
it looks so beat everyone nobody is
theme because people with money get like
Louie Vuitton or whatever you did Samson
I got my oh that was way too expensive a
to me now I'm like man what were you
thinking dude take your luggage and just
drag it behind you wherever you're going
I go to the store [ __ ] drag that [ __ ]
behind here people would mean the La
Brea Tar Pits throw it ended oh sure I
just drop my luggage sorry than have to
crane it out you could smuggle diamonds
in your luggage just like that put
[ __ ] stickers on your thing from
places that nobody wants to go to like
Orlando that is the worst fly ever
though because it always has kids on it
going or coming for my man don't not
stop anywhere babies babies cry taken
baby thank you oh there there throw two
people are right here in this spot who's
who advocate for taking babies of this
why yeah be right blue bar we boo them
no why because they just want to go to
Disney just leave the kids you want to
see the little kid [ __ ] move his head
around the Disney Disney they're like
hey take a little larger battle do the
same [ __ ] break [ __ ] one your sister
does that I bet you don't have the same
reaction at a donut shop
no but you know what's out there free
just can't control this man no right I
know so that just admit that you want to
go just admit that you want to go aim it
at least yo isn't my only I wouldn't
want to carry it by baby if I wanted to
you're so heavy
girlfriends are so like you can only go
on certain rides even when you put him
in a [ __ ] sarong wait did you about
that lady in the applicator for a hotel
at Disneyland where no kids were allowed
that's sick she's an adult woman she's
like look I'm sick of the kids like just
get a hotel or a floor I won't say I
like Disney and I don't have kids that's
like going to Chuck E Cheese and be like
can we get the kids out of here play
with Disney cruises people just love
those Disney cruises but they don't like
the kid that sounds like a [ __ ] night
do it don't you probably on a Disney
cruise and I'm in hell oh are you
kidding me imagine all those kids you
paid 15 G's for this cruise or whatever
but then when you have kids it's fun
because the kids get to go run around
and be loud over there and you get to
just chill that is true that's what I
think that's the best about a cruise
take my kids bring them back tomorrow
you go play with those other cloud kids
that's pretty good you know like big
they gotta be somewhere as long as they
don't fall off the boat I was reading an
article that so many people have been
missing from cruise ships in the past
year the [ __ ] can you just drop them off
at the cruise they have a little
bracelet you scan them in pick him up
like a little clock my kids when I went
they were like hey can you pick us up at
midnight little tired my sister's such a
helicopter parent the whole time she got
the boat should be freaking all the kids
falling off the boat and so she couldn't
even enjoy the cruise my wife was like
that and our first cruise my kids
weren't even there they were literally
at home with their grandma and she
looked over the issues are the kids
might fall from America where they're at
home
that's just tentacles dude that's all
I'm the first floor
bears safe that's all chemicals talking
your whites not even bear dude it's just
her body talking yeah yeah oh my heart
hurts yeah like what
that's crazy no there's no Wi-Fi
did your sister wouldn't be able to
enjoy a cruise even if she didn't have
kids did tell me about it dude my
sister's a [ __ ] riot dude
[Music]